the website Kotaku uh Now features a few
AI written articles Microsoft start
which is the homepage that Microsoft
presents to users of its internet
browser recently featured an obituary
with this headline Brandon Hunter
useless at 42 now this is a former NBA
player who died suddenly and that's the
headline that the AI went with he's not
dead he's quote
useless which is sort of true in a
literal sense I suppose but that's not
how humans typic look at death uh and
you would hope that we wouldn't look at
it that way but Microsoft maybe the
biggest tech company on the planet
promoted that story and here's the
amazing thing it didn't cause any kind
of stir at all you probably didn't even
hear about it